le parquet de Paris a ouvert une enquête
pour détournement de fonds publics dans
le cadre de la campagne présidentielle
de Valérie Pécresse et ce après un
signalement envoyé par Julien Bayou le
leader de robes écologie des Verts la
Présidente de la Région Île-de-France
compte porter plainte pour dénonciation
calomnieuse Valérie Pécresse peut à
l'aise quand elle teste un système de
monte-escalier pour les personnes à
mobilité réduite il n'en fallait pas
plus pour que les internautes se
déchaînent il y a les blagues sur son
mauvais score à la présidentielle et le
non remboursement de ses frais de
campagne certains notent une
contradiction avec ce qu'elle disait en
meeting
la séquence est largement détournée
Valérie Pécresse dans l'espace ou dans
le jeu Tetris elle rejoint aussi les
autres mêmes qui ont amusé le web ces
dernières semaines ce soir on revient
sur la convocation de Fabrice dilizio
devant le Conseil de l'Ordre des avocats
je serai donc jugé parce que je suis
vulgaire et impétueuse pour rappel
Fabrice divisio se fait connaître du
grand public pendant la crise sanitaire
en devenant une figure du mouvement
anti-bax en cette vaccination telle
qu'elle est opérée aujourd'hui est un
scandale sanitaire
mais le Conseil de l'Ordre des avocats
lui reproche aujourd'hui son
comportement et ses propos jugés
grossiers qui pourraient nuire à la
profession d'avocat contacté par le
journal Libération Fabrice division a
dénoncé un procès politique élevage
jusqu'à se considérer comme le digne
héritier de Victor Hugo et 2000 Zola en
ce qu'ils étaient vulgaires eux aussi
trois mois d'interdiction d'exercer ont
été requis contre lui la décision sera
rendue au plus tard le 2 novembre on
voit bien qu'à un moment donné on a
basculé dans une société qui accepte
plus cette notion de liberté expression
et c'est d'autant plus curieux si tu
veux qu'on a alors des avocats qui a pas
arrêté de proclamer je suis Charlie et
ben maintenant on sait qu'ils sont
Charlie mais pas des visions
manifestement
pas tout à fait pareil
la liberté non Richard Malka qui a
défendu Charlie a dit la liberté
d'expression c'est le sang qui coule
dans les veines de la démocratie et
charlatan la médecine il y a aussi les
charlatans du droit
moi ce qui m'a frappé aussi dans le
rappel que vous avez fait c'est de voir
un certain nombre de médias de radio de
télévision qui lui ont donné une tribune
voilà parce qu'on parle beaucoup on
regarde beaucoup les réseaux sociaux
parfois certains médias ont aussi un
phénomène d'accélération en donnant une
tribune et en légitimant quelque part
certains personnages qui ensuite gagnent
de l'influence sur les réseaux sociaux
et le côté vu à la télé s'il est passé
sur un plateau c'est quelque part que il
est crédible c'est Patrick Cohen le
génie Patrick Cohen Viriat partout il a
cité France Inter parce qu'il touchait
pas chez d'argent il a été sur Europe 1
c'était un naufrage il est reparti la
queue basse et il est donc chez c'est à
VOUS Patrick Cohen qui a dit vient
d'être évité dans une invité dans une
certaine émission de télé donc il nous a
fait un peu de pub et il veut pas citer
le nom Patrick Cohen voilà Patrick Cohen
voilà qui est quand même le mec qui a
tout raté dans sa carrière et qui vient
donner des leçons aux autres compilation
d'études publiée dans une revue
américaine les chercheurs ont montré que
la mauvaise humeur le bad mood comme ils
disent va entraîner du stress une forme
de léthargie et des conséquences au
niveau hormonal conclusion je les cite
une exposition prolongée à ses émotions
négatives influencent le bon
fonctionnement de votre système
immunitaire pour le dire plus simplement
ce qui boude seront les premiers
attraper une angine cet hiver bien
donner des leçons à fabriquer des vidéos
qui va donner des leçons à vous ici
Patrick Cohen quand même non mais c'est
rigoler c'est fou ça et moi moi je
comprends moi ça me dérange pas qu'on
rate tout mais ne donnez pas de leçon
aux autres
il représente l'échec il vient donner
des des premiers gens bonjour à tous je
suis marjolaine aujourd'hui alors c'est
le moment de faire la paix avec soi-même
surtout que Mercure est trop grade nous
invite à ralentir et à rentrer en soi
belle journée
avec soi-même car Mercure rétrograde et
que Madame qu'est-ce qu'il en pense et
ben je vais dire Jean-Luc Mélenchon pour
le passage pour le panache pour le
plaisir du palage bien sûr à la fois
chez Wick de Milan kim Kardashian était
pétillante dans cette longue robe moule
en Taillette élégante mais peu pratique
que ce soit pour marcher ou pire monter
les escaliers
cette vidéo postée sur Tik Tok par
l'ancienne assistante de la star a déjà
été vu plus de 7 millions de fois mais
Kim Kardashian reste souriante en toute
circonstance
on valide
il a essayé d'être président pas réussi
après c'est Premier ministre pas réussi
il a essayé missile de France pas réussi
je me dis peut-être il tente l'ours
gros félidé gros ongulé gros ongulé
l'animal qui figure sur le panneau
passage d'animaux sauvages c'est un gros
onglet c'est un gros ongulé la réponse
mission reconquête ça s'appelle parce
que faire toujours une mise à jour avec
les femmes faut toujours voilà lui
plaire donc je sais que ce qu'elle aime
ça l'aime bien manger donc je l'amène
dans un endroit où on va bien manger
j'ai éclaté le PEL un plan un plan
épargne logement je l'ai éclaté pour
pouvoir lui offrir ce ce petit
restaurant donc on se met à l'abri c'est
l'orage et la cata et bon ben j'avais
mon chéri à gauche puis je regarde la
personne à droite pour la saluer et puis
je vois que les gens autour regardent
aussi puis c'était Francky Vincent et là
il vous a dit mais dis-moi tu es toute
mouillé avec cette pluie tropicale il
vous a parlé il était pas très content
d'être mouillé lui d'être d'abord
[Musique]
parce que le clitoris les hommes ont mis
tellement longtemps à le trouver que ça
m'étonnerait qu'on le trouve aussi
facilement et rapidement sur les
dauphins
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire par là
je sais pas comment faire
je te jure pour de vrai